Moxon Spencer has an answer Jill
McDonald the Halfords chief executive
and the former UK boss of McDonald's
will be joining the company in October
to head up his clothing home and beauty
division and Nestor struggled in recent
years with poor sales in his non-food
divisions but the firm's chief executive
Steve Rowe who took up the top job last
year has pledged to turn things around
joining me now to discuss this is
Kirsten McGregor head of news content at
the fashion magazine Draper so Kirstie
she's a fashion novice she's never
worked in fashion before can this work
yeah I mean it was a big surprise this
morning and it's already attracted some
criticism because she doesn't have that
fashion background and clothing has been
the one division of Marks and Spencer
that's really struggled and they're
gonna rely heavily on the existing
internal team they've promoted Joe
Jenkins and so she's looking after
clothing and she'll report into Jill's
so and you know I think they've they've
really put all their bets on that team
having the product knowledge that can
support her in this role and yet she's
not without a pretty impressive CV I
mean she was at British Airways for 16
years knows an awful lot about marketing
and branding you know she did a
fantastic job at McDonald's UK Halfords
their share prior prices down nearly
three percent today so obviously
investors they're sorry to see her go I
mean though you know this is a talented
woman were talking about yeah there's no
doubt she's she's respected as a leader
and she what she seems to bring to the
role really is she's able to drive
growth through a focus on the customer
and that's something that Marks &
Spencer is sorely needs that something
that as CEO Steve Earle has recognized
that they've lost that focus on the
customer so presumably that's been the
real reason that they've brought her
into this role and what about the other
challenges that she faces I mean Marks &
Spencer being quite explicit that
they've managed to avoid passing on the
cost of the weaker pound today through
hedging that's probably going to unwind
at some point so it gets tougher for
them from here doesn't it it does and
there is also the added pressure of
there's a lot of discounting on the high
street with fashion retailers so there's
that additional pressure on them and to
sort out their pricing they've been
trying to bring down the prices and a
lot of their lines and as it is - to
make sure they've got the right price of
right time so they can the right price
first so that they can sell everything
full price and then there's this
pressure costs are going up so that's
something she's absolutely going to have
to look at is how they keep their cost
base as low as possible when they
sterling is a week that was interesting
thing that Steve wrote did didn't he I
mean he wanted to wean them off
discounts and so he lowered prices
across the piece but they are selling
more items at full price now yes and
that seems to have what started show
some benefits they also reduced the
number of promotions that they ran last
year and I think that's been quite
beneficial because people want to I
think the MLS customers looking for a
value for money but not necessarily and
for everything to be on sale all the
time so in the last quarter that they've
reported on their clothing and home
sales were up 3.1 percent is it too
early to say they'd already turn the
corner I think it is and and Steve rule
was quite careful to say you know this
doesn't necessarily mean that we're
entering a period of sustained growth in
clothing at home and but it's a good
sign of course and some of the stuff
they've done around taking out some of
their slightly more tired in-house
brands that they had and making their
clothing offer and more streamlined and
a bit clearer to the customer has stood
them in good stead and that's you know
it's good time really for Jill to be
coming in I'm what about the job itself
Kirsty I mean it's been a graveyard for
people tipped for the top of M&S Cake
Boss Doc John Dickson to name just a
couple yes I mean it there's no doubt
it's it's sort of is pegged as one of
the hardest jobs in retail and and and
it is it certainly is that you know M&S
is and it's a very large business it's
quite complicated it's got quite a rigid
structure it's not they're not able to
make decisions and kind of act on them
as far as quickly as others and so
that's one thing that she will come up
against is trying to get some of those
you know her strategy trying to get it
in place quite quickly